an addictive new season of you has
arrived on Netflix as serial stalker Joe
heads to LA in search of a fresh start
and perhaps a true love story
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video I'm discussing the ending
of season two of you revealing all the
clues that predicted the big twist in
the finale and explaining what that
final shot really means for season three
we will of course be talking spoilers so
take care if you're not all caught up
the final episode of season two
appropriately titled
Love Actually explains the twist that
love is as dark and warped as Joe and
also a serial killer like him Joe at
this point love has just murdered
Candice in cold blood
something foreshadowed right from the
very first episode when Joe arrives in
LA and sees the body of a redhead girl
lying in a pool of blood that was just
an actress filming a scene but the
placement of the heart-shaped sunglasses
and the black leather jackets were the
first sign that Candice wouldn't make it
out of LA alive and as love reveals how
and why she did what she did the
parallels between her and Joe become
even more striking love killed Delilah
and Candice because they were both
obstacles in the way of her forming a
family with Joe similar to how Joe
killed Benji and peach in season one
when he saw them as being in the way of
his relationship with BEC right from the
moment they met love latched on to Joe
as a means to fulfill her fantasy of
having a happy family I knew right away
in my gut I recognized something in you
a little darkness the made us storybook
more real I started to fantasize again
in the first episode it's love he makes
a move on Joe covering his plan to
accidentally bump into her and like Joe
love is able to charm those around her
something Joe immediately picks up on oh
you have a way with people I just like
you again the same as Joe love is
perceptive and she immediately
recognizes the darkness in him and
compares it to herself yeah I thought
about getting you something happy but
let's face it what you're more
interested in is something smart and
complex a little dark that's what makes
you feel at home how do you know that
uncus me tune after Candice reveals the
truth about Joe's real identity to
Quinn's love begins to investigate him
more thoroughly but his dark past
doesn't deter her one bit
she steals the keys to his creepy lockup
where she finds his cage and figures out
the truth about back and Joe's
relationship I devoured your dead exes
book front to back all the articles or
the think pieces reading between the
lines and I realized one of your back
was unspecial and mediocre and it's very
similar to how Joe felt about Beck's
original boyfriend Benji I do understand
something about you now back you somehow
think this guy is all you deserve love
even seems to admire Joe's brutal
actions seeing them as a mirror of her
own violent past you did some terrible
things but that's what sensitive people
do when they're trapped in a bad
relationship
by the way love's affinity for knives
and murder was signaled early on in the
season when we see her butchering a rack
of ribs in a scene that's intercut with
shots of joe chopping up Jasper's dead
body and loves preference for slashing
her victims in the throat was also
hinted at when she faked attacks Joe in
the neck with a toy wolf during her
family's wellness weekend so love maybe
what Joe originally considered his soul
mate but he actually seems disappointed
in the love he found in her by the end
of the season and he ponders this at
Lucy and sunrises wedding all I've ever
wanted is to love and be well to play
something really true me too is that
what we are soul mates
is this what real love is knowing and
accepting anything I think his state of
an e stems from his twisted beliefs
about romantic love mixed with his
confused feelings over whether he's
really a good or bad person on the one
hand Joe still harbors delusions of
himself as a nice guy and Savior the
hero
races to the cage he raises the door and
steps inside eager to set Delilah free
and begin the rest of his life and in
the first episode he even claims he's a
changed man I don't fantasize to some
impossible version of a woman I barely
know however we quickly see he's
repeating similar patterns to what he
did with BEC and by the time of the
finale love herself accuses Joe of
glossing over the true
with his own warped version of reality
because while I was seeing you really
seeing you you weren't busy gazing at a
goddamn fantasy a perfectly imperfect
girl you saw what you wanted to see in
season 2 Joe keeps making the point that
he's trying to change especially after a
vision of Bek confronts him over her
murder in the second episode
unlike Benji who he caged then killed in
season 1 he lets his first captive will
go free and the two murders he does
commit don't seem to be premeditated the
first is in self-defense when Jasper
attacks him and Henderson was pushed
down the stairs it he tried to escape as
Joe's original plan was to have
Henderson confess his crimes on camera
but we have to remember that much of
what we see in you is presented through
Joe's point of view and that he is an
unreliable narrator who spends a good
deal of his time rationalizing his own
often creepy and violent behavior Joe
may have saved Ally from Henderson both
after he traps a sleazy celebrity he's
forced to consider how much difference
there really is between Henderson and
himself Joe believes his actions are
noble but Henderson quickly dismantles
that illusion you feel like you're a
piece of [ __ ] so you're trying to be a
hero ruining my life is not going to
save you from your demons were the same
no no I'm nothing like you we know of
course that Joe is manipulated drugged
knocked out and trapped people to
fulfill his own desires and he's even
killed them Henderson has done similar -
the killing except he's targeted
underage girls
so who's worse it's a difficult and
unsettling question that Joe is
definitely not willing to address we're
nothing alike he's trying to win with
words and ideas that add up to nothing
he is bad someone needs to stop him and
he knows it in a way Henderson and love
are two sides of the same coin for Joe
as they both force him to look at
himself and reflect on his own actions
and he feels threatened and absolutely
terrified by that no no this isn't me
this isn't me anymore
I didn't want to do I didn't do that as
co-creators Sara cam
part of what they're exploring in the
show is the ultimate question of how
self a word joke can get and even the
showrunners have said that they don't
really know the ultimate answer to that
yet Joe's inability to properly confront
and deal with his past crimes continues
through the season in the sixth episode
he plans to go to Candace's air B&B to
abduct her and presumably kill her once
and for all and in the eighth episode
when forty pretends to be back to
reenact her murder Joe begins to hear
Beck's voice accusing him and he can't
handle it you're not special you're
broken I could never love you you were
the bad thing you were the thing that
you should have killed so he begins to
strangle for T for real just as he did
with back then later when forty asks Joe
how do you think dr. Nikki hoodies
sociopathy for so long Joe justifies the
actions of Beck's killer
that's himself of course with yet more
self-delusions
why do you have to be sociopath maybe
he's a man who would do anything for
love later on a vision of Joe's mother
tells him people like us don't change
I've changed then why are you already
thinking of ways to get rid of 40 like
Lady Macbeth Joe sees his own
culpability and complicity in the deaths
of those around him in a vision of his
own bloodied hands and when Joe
discovers that 40 is actually cracked a
code hidden in Beck's autobiography that
it was her ex-boyfriend who killed her
and not dr. Nikki he grabs a piece of
glass and goes to kill 40 he doesn't
follow through but that's only because
he hears about forties childhood trauma
with the family's murdered own pair and
after Joe thinks that he's killed
Delilah himself he begins to believe
that he deserves to be punished I'm done
with excuses I'm done blaming everyone
else for the things I've done it's time
I take responsibility that a cage is
where I belong this idea fits in with
the literary reference to Dostoyevsky's
novel crime and punishment which
appeared in both the first and last
episodes of season 2 in crime and
punishment the hero willingly walks into
exile he is killed but he's also found
love
and if he repents he can be redeemed he
and the woman he loves can be saved
dr. Nikki echo is a similar idea about
deserving punishment when 40 goes to see
him in prison with evidence that could
prove the therapist didn't kill back dr.
Nikki refuses to cooperate even though
he knows that he's innocent of that
crime because he believes he should be
punished nonetheless for his other sins
I didn't kill back but I'm guilty I'm
guilty of using her she's not the first
bad person I'm exactly where I deserved
however Joe seems willing to switch how
he feels about whether he deserves to be
punished although he says he's now
trapped in a cage force deliver the
woman he no longer loves which you could
see as a sort of fitting punishment in
the very final scene we see him quickly
revert to his old tricks I had no idea
that the cage I was building all this
time was a trap for me but that's not
how destiny works is it this is just the
beginning because this is where I had to
be exactly where I had to be to meet you
as we can see Joe has started on a new
delusional path twisting reality and
pretending to himself that falling for
Candice Beck and love were just errors
in a greater scheme blips along the path
of Destiny to meet a literate and
literal girl next door now this scene is
clearly teasing a setup for season three
and just before I get to that and
explain why we're very likely to get at
least two more seasons before Joe
perhaps gets the justice he deserves I
want to let you know that thanks to this
video sponsor Nord VPN all our viewers
can get a very special holiday deal of
81 percent off Nords fantastic Virtual
Private Network as well as for bonus
months for free plus free access to the
Nord password manager just visit Nord
VPN comm slash flicks or tap the link in
the video description so to understand
what will happen next season we need to
remember that by the very end Joe isn't
in love with love anymore after she
revealed her true nature to Joe his
romantic illusion was shattered and when
love refused to let Joe out of the cage
he said to himself that he would do what
Beck did to him and
pretend to love her what did Baek do in
this situation I love you right she
pretended you're asking me to see you to
love you I don't know what to feel love
but I know what to do
in fact Jo almost kills love until she
reveals that she's pregnant and carrying
his baby this is the only thing that
stopped him from murdering her as
protecting children as something that Jo
responds to in particular he went out of
his way in both seasons even putting
himself in danger to protect both Paco
and Ellie and even tried to help Delilah
perhaps because of what Henderson did to
her as a child this'll probably relates
back to how Jo feels about his own
troubled childhood and so he sympathizes
with children and wants to help them at
the end of the season this is how Jones
sees himself I'm ready to meet my
daughter I'm ready to be the good father
I never had to make the family I always
dreamed of the one she deserves however
whether Jo really sticks around is
immediately undermined at the very end
as we see him beginning to stalk the
woman next door
we know he believes he's trapped himself
in a cage with love so it's quite likely
he will try and escape
perhaps with his daughter even and run
to somewhere far from LA for anyone who
isn't already aware this TV show is
based on the books new and hidden bodies
by author Caroline kepner's and she
already has two new books planned in the
series according to E w the third book
we'll see Jo moved to the Pacific
Northwest with a plan to become a family
man in his own unique way now the TV
show has deviated from the books in
various significant ways but if Jo needs
to leave LA in a hurry say because love
catches him creeping on their neighbor
and tries to kill him then fleeing to
another state feels like something he
would do given that's what he did when
Candace returned to confront him in New
York he might also run off with his
daughter to get away from the clutches
of the powerful and corrupt Quinn family
and remember that he's still in contact
with will in Manila who could help him
get set up with new identities and a new
location and given the popularity of the
show I can't see the showrunners wanting
to end Jo's story in the third season
either especially as there is at least a
fourth book planned in the series which
means that I expect it's unlikely Jo
will see justice for any of his crimes
until season
or at which point perhaps Candace's
prediction will eventually come true
murder has a way of following you and
you're not getting away with it
on the subject of being stalked online
if you want to secure yourself from
hackers malicious websites and even your
own Internet service provider selling
your online browsing history to
advertisers then a VPN is essential the
VPN creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and a VPN server
stopping your ISP or any other agencies
from tracking you online reading your
emails private messages or what websites
you're visiting
unlike free VPNs Nord is superfast with
more than five thousand servers in over
60 countries and when I put it to the
test
I was still able to get blisteringly
fast download speeds over my home
connection Nord VPN is also great in
helping you bypass any blocks on videos
or websites which aren't viewable in
your country with Nord VPN you can
quickly pick a server in any country and
then browse the Internet as if you were
there
Nords VPN even unlocks Netflix shows
that may not be available in your home
country the interface is amazingly
intuitive and you can connect up to six
devices at the same time so you can keep
your mobile devices and laptops safe
whenever you're traveling or using
insecure public Wi-Fi in a coffee shop
for example on top of that Nord VPN
offers a unique feature called cyber sec
which provides ad blocking and
protection against malware and Nord has
a no log policy meaning it doesn't
record any of your browsing with our
special holiday deal Nord VPN are
offering all our viewers up to 81
percent off new subscriptions an
additional four months for free and
access to the Nord password manager at
no additional cost
just visit Nord VPN comm slash flicks or
tap the link in the video description to
access the offer for just the price of a
monthly cup of coffee you can secure
your internet browsing from spies and
hackers that's Nord VPN dot-com slash
flicks for a huge 81 percent discount
and four months entirely free so how do
you feel about the ending for Jo and
love in season two and what would you
like to see happen in season three
comment with your thoughts below and if
you enjoyed this I'll be reviewing new
seasons
chilling adventures of sabrina lucifer
and stranger things as they come out so
make sure you subscribe to get all my
new videos tapleft for my next video or
tap write for another video you're sure
to like thanks for watching and see you
next time here PK movie lovers